T
ACTUALLY CAME TRUE.
TULSI GABBARD IS A FORMER
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE AND
FORMER HAWAII CONGRESSWOMAN.
TULSI, IT IS AMAZING WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE FACTS, WHEN YOU TAKE
AWAY ALL THE DISINFORMATION THAT
THE LEFT AND THE MEDIA THROWS AT
YOU, THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM IN
THIS COUNTRY.
I BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE ARE SEEING
THROUGH THE NOISE, DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT?
>> I TOO.
I THINK ALL THESE DIFFERENT
EXAMPLES YOU ARE SHOWING, JESSE,
JUST POINT TO A FEW THINGS
NUMBER ONE HOW GROSSLY OUT OF
TOUCH THEY ARE WITH THE RELATES
AND STRUGGLES OF EVERYDAY
AMERICANS ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
THEY ARE EXPOSING HOW DIRECTLY
THEY ARE LYING TO US.
TRYING TO PAINT THESE ROSY
PICTURES THAT ARE BLATANTLY
FALSE.
AND THINKING THAT WE ARE TOO
STUPID TO SEE THROUGH THEIR
LIES.
AND, THEREFORE, EXPOSING THEIR
ARROGANCE.
THEY SEE THEMSELVES AS THE
RULERS OF THIS EMPIRE.
WE ARE THEIR SUBJECTS.
THEY KNOW WHAT'S BEST.
AND WE JUST GOT TO -- WE JUST
GOT TO GO ALONG.
WE JUST GOT TO COMPLY.
THE REALITY IS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE LIVING WHAT'S TRUE.
WHICH IS NOT THIS ROSY FANTASY
PICTURE THEY ARE PAINTING.
YOU KNOW, I JUST SPENT A FEW
DAYS WITH SERVICE MEMBERS IN
SOUTH FLORIDA, JESSE.
AND THEY ARE STRUGGLING NOT ONLY
WITH INFLATION BUT WITH
INCREDIBLY HIGH COST OF LIVING
THERE HOUSING, FOOD NEAREST
WALMART OR COSTCO 6 HOUR DRIVE.
I SPOKE WITH A SERGEANT FIRST
CLASS WIFE AND FIVE KIDS.
PAYING ALMOST $5,000 FOR ON BASE
APARTMENT ESSENTIALLY THAT IS IN
ATROCIOUS AND UNSAFE CONDITIONS.
THERE IS LIMITED ON BASE
HOUSING.
IN ORDER TO MOVE INTO IT THEY
HAVE TO SIGN A WAIVER SAYING
THEY ARE OKAY WITH LIVING WITH
ASBESTOS AND MOLD AND LADY PAINT
AND FAMILIES AT RISK.
SO MANY EXAMPLES BIDEN SAYING
HERE IS HOW MANY BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WE ARE GOING TO DISH OUT
TO COUNTRIES ALL AROUND THE
WORLD.
MEANWHILE WE HAVE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND SERVICEMEN AND WOMEN
AND THEIR FAMILIES STRUGGLING
AND SUFFERING RIGHT HERE AT
HOME.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT AND
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF WHO IS NOT
ONLY OUT OF TOUCH WITH REALITY
BUT FRANKLY DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND OUR
WELL-BEING AND THAT IS WHEREAS
WE HEAD TOWARD THE POLLS IN JUST
A FEW WEEKS HERE, WHAT I WANT TO
SEE COMING OUT OF THAT IS ON
ELECTION DAY THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WIN.
BECAUSE, REGARDLESS OF PARTY, WE
NEED LEADERS WHO WILL PUT THE
WELL-BEING AND THE INTEREST OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FIRST AND
UNFORTUNATELY, THAT'S WHAT WE
HAVE BEEN MISSING HERE FOR A
REALLY LONG TIME AND ESPECIALLY
MISSING IT FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Jesse: WELL SAID.
WHEN YOU SAY YOU WANT TO PUT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FIRST, THEY SAY
THAT'S FASCIST.
THAT'S THE KIND OF THING YOU ARE
DEALING WITH HERE.
IT'S GOBBLE HAVE A REAL
CONVERSATION.